the game is going to involve three dots
they could be anywhere I said I was
gonna put them in a triangle that's kind
of difficult to avoid it's not
particularly meant to be an equal
triangle as call it a b c and i'm going
to put a starting point just randomly on
the paper and all we're going to do is
roll this lovely dice die dice who cares
to decide which point to go towards and
we're getting whatever point we choose
we're going to go half way so let's call
a 1 4 2 if we get one or two we'll go to
half way towards a and this is going to
be 3 or 4 and C can be 5 4 6 so it's
just roll - so I need to go half way to
the point there's been chosen at random
which is a in this case so um we could
measure this for the sake of speed I'm
just going to go roughly halfway I think
you can believe that if we run aligned
there we're going to get further up
there and we're going to keep doing this
for a while we're iterating so we're
repeating we get the last result and
work from that but the start point could
be anywhere I could have put a start
point outside the triangle I can still
head towards one of these dots let's
just see what happens when I keep
rolling guys
I just wanted to again so from that was
the dot I had before and I've gone half
way from the previous dot and that's my
halfway point so if I roll this one
again one doctor wish I'd rigged this
now from this dot the last I had halfway
towards the 1 so it's going to we're
just a mning towards one this is
unlikely to keep going but I then place
your bets now for for is the the B dot
so I've got a good kind of from the
previous dot halfway on this line is
about there and I've jumped a long way
this time
one back towards a so getting there and
I'm going to keep doing this so you've
got the idea thing from the previous dot
we go towards one of these two your diet
is rig ready fix excellent we've gone
all the way
this was the dot kind of halfway is
there six one back up here too
sighs or we don't here I'm going to do
this a lot now really but maybe this we
were speeding up I'm bored math but it's
not that exciting the interesting things
are happening we've created kind of some
lines but beta glimpse made a bunch of
dots on the paper it's possible that
something interesting would happen if I
could do this quick enough that I
wouldn't get so bored I have to stop but
maybe we want computer to do this we
have a problem with a computer though
and random numbers like you generating
random numbers is difficult when a
computer has to do with its told but
let's go Parker issue for another video
for EPS if I can get recruited to roll
the dice for me and put the dot on then
we could see what happens quickly and
let's do that the screen has just as we
had we've got three dots they're not
even in a nice equilateral triangle they
can be anywhere this thing says trace
point it's just going to trace where
that goes and the computer is with its
magic going to choose a B or C and move
that point halfway accurately this time
so you see that it's leaving a mark
anywhere it goes so it's going to a
several times and roads jump to B and
then back to a and then to C but I mean
doing a running commentary on this for
any longer than I have done is probably
not going to make anyone's day so let's
speed it up a little bit faster and you
begin to see something still led to the
structure I have the outline get defined
quite well
but I'm just going to speed up a little
bit more the outcome of this I genuinely
think is slightly surprising but also a
little time frightening because you
start to wait is that structure I'm
seeing am i imagining that how is it
dodging those little weird patches a
little why that never going in those
they're definitely triangles now and
then I start to see a shape which
actually if you've done any sort of
investigating bits of recreational mass
this is a familiar shape it's full of
triangles it looks like that trace point
wherever is going which is definitely
going randomly and rig this is doing a
different every time we run it but it's
dodging those triangles and it's making
a shape which I'm think everyone can see
now which is this acordes if pinch the
gasket sends up all over the place this
is a fractal thing you get actually you
can see now I think we've got enough to
see that the big triangle has a black
triangle little and three copies of
itself around the outside of that black
bit but then each copy of itself has a
black bit in the middle and three copies
around itself and that's why fractal is
the self similar thing you zoom in and
you see a little copy of itself but the
fact this is genuinely coming from
rolling a dice you're on the computer
and doing it quickly makes me I know
just slightly disturbed about reality I
would have thought every point has had a
chance of being filled at some stage but
there are lots of areas that we just
never get touched right and you can rig
it so I I said you could start anywhere
right so I could start with my point
right in the middle and then we
definitely have a point right in the
middle in that black but what happens if
you iterate enough it veers away from
that so the long term behavior is what's
interesting but even if you start in a
black thing the the random going half
way moves you away from that black area
and you actually the technical term for
this shape is called an attractor some
people you may have heard of these
things called strange attractors in
chaos theory when it's kind of advanced
mass in the end but this shape is the
attraction and it's also just it's just
pretty the fact that random behavior
produces something which is very
structured it is a nice outcome well we
had three points I mean we could add
four we get a five we can pick a number
and probably a whole number otherwise
countering the point is difficult we
could have four points and say well
let's roll a dice or a four-sided dice
as before to go to one of those what
pattern would you get you could say
instead of going half way go a third of
the way or 3/4 the way what will happen
do any of them make pounds do they go
chaotic people who have spent a long
time fiddling with the rules it's nice
to find out for yourself but there's one
rule I'll show you which does something
nobody really expected so I'm not going
to go into details this is worth looking
up but I've got a red shape in a blue
shape and they're kind of just
summarizing two possible outcomes of the
rule like we'll start with a point and
with some probability would go to one of
the corners of the red triangle but with
a small probability will flip over to
the blue triangle and every time you
kind of roll the dice to see where to go
you follow this slightly more
complicated set of rules but just
they're just random like you go here
with a certain probability and then you
flip back the red one with red
probability and if you look up this
particular rule you get this picture
after a while you start to see these
green dots appearing in what looks like
a very structured way in fact it becomes
very obvious if you run it long enough
that the picture you're getting looks
like something real looks like fun and
crazy this is called Barnes Lee's firm
compare it with a real firm it's
surprisingly accurate this is a nice
example of how you don't have to draw
something natural by hand all the
information for this firm is captured in
a few lines of probability like the
rules of the game are the fern or are a
picture of a thern it's actually really
useful if you want to program video game
graphics you don't have to war every
tree every fern so if you can just kind
of store all the Korean firms as a rule
as they win it whenever you want fun you
just do that for a while that is a much
easy way to sort of that cap and lots of
natural things can ax have this fractal
structure itself similar things which
means you can generate them by iterating
stuff genuinely good graphics coming
from the fractal generated graphics
rather than hand-painted to get the
structure of a tree on repeat if you
just add one tree and you copied it
becomes really obvious when you're
running around the forest like this just
to compute the forest but if it looks
has this natural sort of variation with
some randoms in it you get much more
realistic looking
trees and ferns
our thanks to the great causes plus for
making this extra video possible if you
have a thirst for knowledge and you
probably do because you're watching
numberphile then you really should check
these guys out from exoplanets too chess
from ancient Rome to English grammar
you're going to find something that
fascinates you among this huge library
of online videos each is taught by
world-class experts from organizations
like the Smithsonian National Geographic
all the top universities unlimited
access to the full catalog starts from
as low as 14.99 a month but you can sign
on for a free trial to see just how good
it is go to the great courses plus.com
slash numberphile to check them out
there's also a link in the video
description I'd recommend this one about
the Tibetan Plateau and the Himalayas
bit of an interest of mine it's got some
really cool stuff about how mountains
are formed and would you believe it it's
part of a 36 per series of lectures
called the world's greatest geological
wonders have a look at that that's
seriously interesting stuff dead address
again the great courses plus calm slash
numberphile or the link in the
description to start you off with that
free trial